Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to the restishistory.com and join the club. That is, the rest is history.com. Searchlight Pictures presents, The Roses, only in theaters, August 29th.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如需每周独家加更节目、无广告收听、提前解锁系列内容以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 the restishistory.com 并加入会员俱乐部。也就是说，theresistishistory.com。探照灯影业呈献，《玫瑰夫妇》，8月29日仅在影院上映。
From the director of Meet the Parents and the writer of Poor Things, comes The Roses, starring Academy Award winner, Olivia Coleman, Academy Award nominee, Benedict Cumberbatch, Andy Samburg, Kate McKinnon, and Allison Janney. A hilarious new comedy filled with drama, excitement, and a little bit of hatred, proving that marriage isn't always a bed of roses. See The Roses, only in theaters, August 29th.
本片由《拜见岳父大人》导演与《可怜的东西》编剧联袂打造，《玫瑰夫妇》汇聚了奥斯卡奖得主奥利维娅·科尔曼、奥斯卡奖提名者本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇、安迪·萨姆伯格、凯特·麦金农以及艾莉森·珍妮。这是一部充满戏剧性、刺激感和丝丝恨意的全新爆笑喜剧，证明了婚姻并非总是一帆风顺。敬请观赏《玫瑰夫妇》，8月29日仅在影院上映。
Get tickets now. Way down in Merry England, the home of Johnny Bulls. Where the English drink their glasses, they drink them brimming full, saying here's to Merry England, likewise our Britain's brave, the champions we are, o'er the land and o'er the wave. Way down in Merry England, all in the bloom of spring, where English burly champions stood stripped off in the ring to fight that noble Heenan, the gallant son of Troy, to try his British muscle on the bold Benicia boy. Two heavy flags were hoisted, that floated her the ring. On one there was a tiger already for a spring. On the other was an eagle, a gallant bird she was, for she had a bunch of thunderbolts and held them in her claws.
立即购票。遥远的快乐英格兰，约翰·布尔的故乡。英格兰人端起酒杯，斟得满满当当，高呼为快乐英格兰干杯，也为了我们勇敢的英国，那些屹立于陆地与波涛之巅的英雄。遥远的快乐英格兰，正值百花盛开的春日，粗壮的英国勇士们赤条条地走上擂台，去迎战那位高贵的希南，特洛伊的英雄之子，用他的英国肌肉来对阵大胆的贝尼西亚男孩。两面沉重的旗帜高高飘扬，在擂台上招展。一面绣着一头蓄势待发的猛虎。另一面绣着一只雄鹰，多么矫健的鸟儿，因为她的爪子抓着一束雷霆。
Oh, the pennies they were tossed and their melee did begin. Their bets on Sayers and Heenan, two-on-one, came rushing in. They fought like noble heroes till one received a blow, which caused a crimson tide from young young young. Hennon's nose to flow. The first blood for Johnny Bull, Old England shouts for joy. But the following cheers arose for the bold Benicia boy. The tiger rose within him, like lightning in his eye, saying, smile away, old England,
哦，硬币抛出，混战就此拉开。押注赛尔斯和希南的人潮二比一蜂拥而至。他们像高贵的英雄一样战斗，直到其中一人挨了一拳，引得年轻的、年轻的、年轻的希南的鼻子血流如注。老英格兰人为主力约翰的第一滴血欢呼雀跃。但随之而来的欢呼声，是献给大胆的贝尼西亚男孩的。猛虎在他心中苏醒，眼中闪烁着闪电，仿佛在说：笑吧，老英格兰，
but Johnny, mind your eye. So that's the beginning of a lovely poem. It's the beginning. Yes, it's the beginning song. How long does it go on for? It goes on for much, it goes on for 42 rounds. It's a poem called Heenan and Sayers, and it was by Mrs. Elwood Nickerson, written in about, we don't know, about 1860, 61, in New England. And this poem is celebrating the fight of the century, the clash between Tom Sayers and John Heenan on the 17th of April 1860.
但约翰，当心你的眼睛。所以，这是一首可爱诗篇的开端。这是个开端。是的，这是开场曲。这首歌要唱多久？它唱得很长，足足有42个回合。这首诗叫《希南与赛尔斯》，由埃尔伍德·尼科森夫人创作于大约——我们也不太确定——大约1860年或1861年，在新英格兰。这首诗是在歌颂那场世纪之战，即1860年4月17日汤姆·赛尔斯与约翰·希南之间的巅峰对决。
Tom, are you a great boxing aficionado? Not hugely, but as you will know, I am a fan of British muscle, because I've actually just come from the gym where I've, been toning my British muscle. Oh, that's a nice image. So I feel absolutely prepped and ready for this. Good. I mean, one thing I am, well, at least I used to be a fan of, was going off to fields in Hampshire.
汤姆，你是个狂热的拳击迷吗？不算太狂热，但如你所知，我是英国肌肉的粉丝，因为我刚从健身房出来，一直在那里锻炼我的英国肌肉。哦，那画面真美。所以我感觉自己已经完全准备好迎接这个话题了。很好。我的意思是，我曾经算是个粉丝的一件事，就是去汉普郡的田野里。
Right. To engage in illegal activities. Oh, my word. Oh, no. So as name checked by Jarvis Cocker in his famous song, Sorted for Ease and Whiz. Right. This is a lovely image. And reading about this fight, which takes place illegally in a field in Hampshire, I, I
没错。去从事非法活动。哎呀我的天。哦，不。正如贾维斯·科克在他那首著名的歌《Sorted for Ease and Whiz》中所提及的那样。没错。这画面太美了。读到这场在汉普郡的田野里非法举行的比赛时，我、我
I couldn't help but think about how, you know, how the traditions of Mary England run deep. So people, you know, in the 90s weren't gathering to watch boxing matches, but they were gathering to celebrate. To go to raves. Going to raves. So there's kind of deep continuities, aren't there? Frankie. Well, I didn't expect that to, that angle to be the angle of choice.
我不禁想到，你知道的，快乐英格兰的传统是多么根深蒂固。所以人们，你知道的，在90年代聚在一起不是为了看拳击比赛，而是为了庆祝。去参加锐舞派对。去参加锐舞派对。所以这里面有一种深层的延续性，对吧？弗兰基。好吧，我可没料到这个角度会成为首选。
Well, I've introduced British muscle in ease and whiz. So we thought we would dig into the story behind this extraordinary clash between Tom Sayers and John Heenan. what it tells us about Britain, America, Britishness, sport. It's about sport above all, isn't it? It's about... But it's about what sport means. But also in the long run, how it comes to be tamed and codified and in a way made kind of posher, as we will see.
好吧，我提到了英国肌肉以及迷幻药。所以我们觉得应该深入挖掘这场汤姆·赛尔斯与约翰·希南之间非凡对决背后的故事。它告诉了我们关于英国、美国、英国特色以及体育的什么。最重要的是关于体育，对吧？它是关于……但它关乎体育的意义。而且从长远来看，正如我们将看到的，它最终是如何被驯服、被编纂成文，并以某种方式变得更加体面的。
Yes, I think that's true. And we are joined by very much a friend of the rest is history. So listeners who heard our episode on Orwell will remember him. He is Professor Robert Coles, Emeritus Professor at Dumfutonford University, and author of the brilliant book, This Sporting Life, Sport and Liberty in England, 1760 to 1960, in which this fight plays a kind of lead role as a whole chapter about this fight. Rob, welcome back to the rest of his history. Thank you. Great to be back.
是的，我也这么认为。而且我们今天请到了一位“历史的余烬”的真正老朋友。听过我们奥威尔那期节目的听众一定还记得他。他是邓富顿福德大学的名誉教授罗伯特·科尔斯教授，也是那本精彩著作《体育生活：1760年至1960年英国的体育与自由》的作者。在这本书中，这场比赛扮演了某种主角般的角色，有一整章都在讲述这场比赛。罗伯、欢迎回到“历史的余烬”。谢谢。很高兴能回来。
So what's going on? You have, to set the scene, it's very early in the morning. It's the 17th of April, 1860. It's a Tuesday. It's in the middle of nowhere, a field in Hampshire. All of these people have gathered to watch these two men knock seven bells out of one another. What is the story behind all this? Yeah, if you want to know what's going on in this field in Hampshire in 1860,
那么，这到底是怎么回事？为了还原当时的情景，时间非常早，那是1860年4月17日，星期二。地点是荒郊野岭，汉普郡的一片田野里。所有这些人都聚集在那里，看着这两个家伙把对方揍得鼻青脸肿。这一切背后的故事是什么？是的，如果你想知道1860年汉普郡的这片田野里到底发生了什么，
what you don't do is read Mrs. Nickerson's poem because it's quite clear that she's not been within a thousand miles of this fight, which took place the year before. It's billed across the Atlantic is the first international heavyweight championship. It's been talked about for 12 months before, and it will be talked about for 40, 50 years afterwards. Generally speaking, journalists and others called it the fight of the century. In many ways, it was really none of those things. and the American, the Irish American who'd come across to do his business, John Camel Heenan, had only had one professional fight in his life, which he'd lost.
你可千万别去读尼科森夫人的诗，因为很明显，她连这场在一年前举行的比赛方圆一千英里之内都没去过。这场比赛在大西洋两岸被宣传为第一场国际重量级锦标赛。在此之前的12个月里，人们一直在谈论它，而在之后的40、50年里，人们也依然会谈论它。一般来说，记者和其他人称之为世纪之战。但在许多方面，它其实根本算不上那些。而且那位来到英国“做生意”的爱尔兰裔美国人约翰·坎内尔·希南，一生中其实只打过一场职业比赛，而且还输了。
So he was a novice, really. His claim to be there was he had a talent for violence. And, right. I don't know if you've seen the wonderful Scorsese film Gangs of New York, but Heenan had operated within those gangs as a minder, as an enforcer, as a publican by day, and a hard man by night. So he was just a hard case, who was chancing his look against the English champion.
所以他其实是个新手。他能出现在那里的唯一资本，就是他有施暴的天赋。而且，没错。我不知道你有没有看过马丁·斯科塞斯那部精彩的电影《纽约黑帮》，希南曾在那些黑帮里充当保镖、打手，白天是个酒店老板，晚上是个狠角色。所以他只是一个靠着和英国拳王碰运气来搏命的狠角色。
The English champion was a very different kettle of fish. Tom Sayers was an out-and-out professional. He'd been fighting since he was 16, born in Brighton, born in the Lanes, and Brighton started fighting at 16 up on the day. downs on the race courses, what the press called casual wages, you know, five minutes done in a corner, money changes hands. In his 20s, Sayers had moved to London, where he had plied his trade as a bricklayer in Camden. Camden was new then, the railway was coming, and Tom did his work
英国拳王可完全是另一回事。汤姆·赛尔斯是一个彻头彻尾的职业选手。他从16岁就开始打拳了，出生在布赖顿，出生在小巷区，布赖顿人从16岁起就在赛马场的丘陵上打拳，也就是媒体所说的临时打工，你知道的，在角落里打上五分钟，钱就易手了。二十多岁时，赛尔斯搬到了伦敦，在卡姆登以当泥瓦匠为生。那时的卡姆登还是个新地方，铁路正在修建，汤姆就在那里
there. He also did part-time fighting and amassed enough money to become a publican. The laurel tree in Bayham Road, Camden, was his pub. And he got married and he had children. And in 1850, aged 24, he had his first out-and-out professional fight. By the time he's facing Heenan in that field, 7 o'clock in the morning, April 1860, he'd had 14 fights, of which he'd lost only one. So what are they there to do? Well, what they're there to do is the most awful thing it would seem possible to imagine.
工作。他还兼职打拳，积攒了足够的钱开了一家小酒馆。卡姆登贝伊姆路的“桂树”酒馆就是他的店。他结了婚，有了孩子。1850年，24岁的他迎来了自己第一场真正意义上的职业比赛。当他在1860年4月清晨7点的那片田野里面对希南时，他已经打了14场比赛，其中只输过一场。那么他们去那里的目的是什么？好吧，他们的目的看起来似乎是你能想象到的最可怕的事情。
They were there to inflict such injuries on each other with their bare hands that one of them was going to be incapable of standing up. Or at any rate, coming to the centre of the ring, the scratch mark, and standing up in that position. That's what they were there to do. Behind this fight really was the New York press and the London press. In New York, we had a sporting newspaper called Porter's Spirit of the Times, and they thought in Heenan they had someone who could relieve the English of their own championship. In Tom Sayers, Bell's life, which was the leading sporting newspaper, Bells thought they had a man who could restore the prize ring to some kind of,
他们去那是为了用赤手空拳在彼此身上造成这样的伤势：其中一个人将无力站立。或者无论如何，无法走到擂台中央的划痕标记处，以那种姿势站立。这就是他们去那里的目的。这场比赛的背后其实是纽约媒体和伦敦媒体的较量。在纽约，我们有一家名为《波特时代精神》的体育报纸，他们认为希南正是能从英国人手中夺走冠军头衔的人。而在汤姆·赛尔斯这边，《贝尔生活报》作为当时的龙头体育报纸，他们认为自己拥有一个能够让奖金擂台恢复某种
honor and respectability, which it had lost in the 1850s and 40s. In the event, both newspapers were wrong, as we shall see. So anyway, Heenan makes it to London, December 1859, and the two men meet at Owen Swift's public house, the horseshoe in Titchbourne Street. If I can just jump in, Owen Swift, he's a fighter himself who has killed people the ring. Is that right? Yeah. Swift has killed three men in the ring. And the last one being Brighton Bill. And he spent his time before magistrates and always got away with it. Rob, how does he get away with it? Well, the legal position of fighting was very unclear. Judges absolutely detested it
荣誉与尊严的人，而这种荣誉和尊严在19世纪40和50年代已经丧失了。事实证明，两家报纸都错了，正如我们将看到的。无论如何，希南于1859年12月抵达伦敦，两人在欧文·斯威夫特的酒馆——蒂奇伯恩街的“马蹄铁”酒馆见面。如果我能插一句，欧文·斯威夫特，他本人就是一个曾在擂台上打死过人的拳手。是这样吗？是的。斯威夫特在擂台上打死过三个人。最后死的是“布赖顿比尔”。他曾多次在治安法官面前受审，但总是能逃脱惩罚。罗伯，他是怎么逃脱的？嗯，打架的法律地位非常模糊。法官们极其痛恨这种行为，
and wanted it finished with. But magistrates found it a lot easier to turn a blind eye. And as we know the police in the middle of the 19th century were not organized or as well informed as they might be. And our magistrates turning a blind eye to it because they are fans, because they're enthusiasts, because they think that it's an expression of British manliness or what's the reason? I don't think so, Tom. I think the reason they're turning a blind eye is, although fights are strictly speaking a breach of the peace and they're very nervous about disorder, stopping one would probably be more dissold at it. Oh, I see. Right.
并希望彻底取缔它。但治安法官们发现睁一只眼闭一只眼要容易得多。而且正如我们所知，19世纪中叶的警察并没有组织起来，或者说没有他们可能的那般消息灵通。我们的治安法官对它睁一只眼闭一只眼，是因为他们是粉丝，是因为他们是狂热爱好者，是因为他们认为这是英国男子气概的表现，还是出于什么原因？我不这么认为，汤姆。我认为他们睁一只眼闭一只眼的原因是，尽管严格来说打架是破坏治安的行为，而且他们对骚乱非常紧张，但制止一场比赛可能会引发更大的骚乱。哦，我明白了。没错。
And more breach of a piece. But above all else, of course, you've got aristocratic patronage. And if you're a, you know, if you're a local country vicar who's also a magistrate, stepping in to stop a fight where there are lords and dukes and gentlemen, you wouldn't last long. So magistrates turned the blind eye, judges pressed for it to be stopped. At law, fighting was odd, mainly it was a breach of the peace, or it could be common assault, or it could be riot, or worse still, it could be manslaughter.
而且会更严重地破坏治安。但最重要的是，当然了，你还得有贵族赞助。如果你是一个（你知道的）当地的乡村牧师，同时也是一名治安法官，结果你介入去制止一场有贵族、公爵和绅士们观看的比赛，你在那个位置上可待不久。所以治安法官们睁一只眼闭一只眼，而法官们则力主将其取缔。在法律上，斗殴很奇怪，主要它被视为破坏治安，或者可能是普通袭击，或者是暴动，更糟糕的是，可能是过失杀人。
And as the century wore on, more and more cases for manslaughter were brought to court. But nothing much happened. I've actually got some boring figures here, which I once spent my time counting. out of 30 tried at the old Bailey for manslaughter in the ring between 1856 and 75. Out of the 30 men, 13 were acquitted and 17 were convicted, but all of them got less than six months in jail. Right. If you're a Carter or a laborer, you tend to get convicted. If you're an old Etonian schoolboy and you've just killed a fellow student, as did happen to Lord Shaftesbury's youngest brother in the 1820s, who was killed in a 60 round fight, you get let off.
随着世纪的推移，越来越多的过失杀人案被带到了法庭上。但其实也没发生什么大事。我这里其实有一些无聊的数据，这些数据是我曾经花时间统计过的。在1856年至1875年间，因在擂台上过失杀人而在老贝利法院受审的30人中，有13人被判无罪，17人被判有罪，但所有人的刑期都不到六个月。没错。如果你是个马车夫或劳工，你往往会被定罪。如果你是一个老伊顿公学学生，刚刚失手打死了一位同校同学——正如1820年代沙夫茨伯里伯爵的小儿子所遭遇的那样，他在一场60个回合的比赛中被杀——你就会被无罪释放。
So that is like the one in Tom Brown School Days with, what's it, slugger, slugger somebody, slugger somebody has a fight behind the gym school? Slugger. Slugger. Slugger, that's right. Slugger Williams fights Tom. Thomas Hughes, who wrote it, knew exactly what he was writing about when he did that. Sorry, we took you off feast, didn't we, by getting into this. So they've met for the first time at Swift's Pub, the two contestants, Heenan and Sayers. And Sayers, exactly. And so the fight is going to happen. But at this point, nobody knows when and where it will happen.
所以这就像《汤姆·布朗求学记》里的那个情节，里面有个叫什么来着，打手，某个打手，某个打手在学校健身房后面打架？打手。打手。打手，没错。打手威廉姆斯和汤姆打架。写下这本书的托马斯·休斯在写那一幕时，完全知道自己在写什么。抱歉，我们刚才扯远了，对吧？所以他们两个参赛者——希南和赛尔斯——在斯威夫特的酒馆第一次见面了。而赛尔斯，确实如此。所以比赛就要举行了。但在此时，没人知道比赛何时何地会举行。
Which, again, it's like raves, isn't it? That people know something's going to happen, but they don't quite know how to get there. And people are waiting to be texted the number and the address. places like that. So it's a bit like that. Exactly. That's a great analogy, actually, a rave. It's exactly that, Tom. It's a rave. Everyone's turning up at London Bridge at 4 a.m. on the morning of the fight. And nobody knows where the fight's going to happen, but they're all buying a ticket for Farmbra. And Rob, when you say everyone, I mean, you really do mean everyone. So Dickens's friend, people say Lord Palmerston's going. Yeah, the Prince Wales. What is the class of person who is who is
这又让我想起了锐舞派对，对吧？人们知道要发生点什么，但又不太清楚该怎么去。大家都在等着接收短信里的号码和地址之类的地方。所以有点像那样。没错。这真是一个绝妙的比喻，锐舞派对。完全就是那样，汤姆。这就是一场锐舞派对。比赛当天早上4点，每个人都涌向伦敦桥。没有人知道比赛会在哪里举行，但大家都在买去法恩伯勒的车票。罗伯，当你指“每个人”时，我是说，你真的是指所有人。所以狄更斯的朋友，有人说帕麦斯顿勋爵也会去。是的，还有威尔士亲王。到底是什么阶层的人
going down on this train to this boxing match? Because it's secret, no one knows where it is. But, of course, everyone does know where it is. Let's just say reports are rather mixed and confused. But generally speaking, we know there's an aristocratic element. We know locals down in Hampshire would probably turn up just to see the play. It's a kind of festival. It's a kind of fair.
会坐这趟火车去看这场拳击比赛？因为它是秘密的，没人知道地点在哪。但是，当然了，每个人其实都知道地点在哪。只能说各种报道相当混杂且混乱。但总的来说，我们知道其中有贵族阶层。我们知道汉普郡当地人可能会为了看热闹而出现。这就像是一种节日。这就像是一个集市。
And then we've got mainly what was called at the time, the fancy or more intellectual people were called the cognoscenti that is there's a kind of following around fighting which is to do with betting it's to do with former fighters known as pugs or pugilists it's to do with aristocrats
然后我们主要拥有的是当时所谓的“行家”或者更具知识分子气息的人被称为“鉴赏家”，也就是说，周围存在着一种围绕着拳击的追星族群体，这与赌博有关，与被称为“拳击手”的前拳击手有关，与
who just will gamble on anything these people know the odds and they'll be at all the big fights from of course the word the fancy we get the word fan So they reckon there's about 1,500 passengers on two trains coming out of London Bridge, 35 carriages on each. Dickensman, I think he's called Holland's Head, claims to be sitting in a compartment with a well-known lord, a well-known poet, and a well-known politician. But he doesn't name names.
那些只要能赌什么都肯下注的贵族有关。这些人深谙赔率，他们会出现在所有的大型比赛中。当然了，我们从“fancy”（行家/狂热爱好者）这个词中得到了“fan”（粉丝）这个词。所以他们估计，从伦敦桥出发的两列火车上大约有1500名乘客，每列车有35节车厢。狄更斯的那位朋友，我想他叫霍兰德·黑德，声称自己和一个知名勋爵、一个知名诗人和一个知名政客坐在同一个车厢里。但他没有指名道姓。
Certainly, when they got to the fight and walked half a mile across muddy fields, and they were met by more security who were handing out chairs to the aristocrats who deserved them and no chairs to the rest. So basically, when you got to the scene of the fight, you could either watch the law being broken sitting down or you could watch the law being broken standing up. And people are placing bets. So betting is obviously an enormous part of this. Is there betting happening in the field? I mean, are there bookmakers there, you know, show, cutting out the odds and stuff. Yes.
当然，当他们到达比赛现场，步行半英里穿过泥泞的田野时，他们遇到了更多的安保人员，这些人在向那些有资格的贵族分发椅子，而其他人则没有。基本上，当你到达比赛现场时，要么你可以坐着看法律被践踏，要么你可以站着看法律被践踏。人们都在下注。所以赌博显然是其中极其重要的一部分。现场有在赌博吗？我是说，那里有庄家吗，开出赔率之类的。是的。
The most important thing to get a fight going, Dom, is steak money. So the two sides place steak bets with each side. And the winner will take the other side's steak. That's the real money in the formal and official money in prize fighting. So Tom's side put £500, £50 pound ago, at a number of London pubs. and Heenan's side did exactly the same. Of course, there would be informal and relentless betting on the fight as the fight progressed. This made it very, very dodgy business. Because the fighters were in the fight and could hear how the odds were changing, ringside, they could themselves change
要让一场比赛顺利进行，最重要的事情就是保证金。所以双方分别向对方交付保证金。而赢家将拿走另一方的保证金。这才是职业拳击中真正的钱，是形式上和官方的钱。因此，汤姆的一方在伦敦的几家酒馆里下了500英镑的保证金，每家50英镑。希南的一方也做了完全一样的事。当然，随着比赛的进行，场外也会有非正式且不断的下注。这让事情变得非常非常危险。因为拳手们身处赛场中，能够听到场边赔率是如何变化的，他们自己就能改变比赛的结果。
the outcome of the fight. So I just wanted to ask you about that. I mean, what is to stop one of them throwing it? Nothing. Right. So how is that regulated or is it not regulated? Well, according to London Rules, 1839, which they're fighting by, you're not meant to go down in one knee unless you've had a proper punch. But how do you measure a proper punch? The only person who knows a proper punch has been landed is the giver and the receiver. If the receiver wants to cheat, which in the parlance is called a cross and go down and lose and is bet against himself, he's made a lot of money. Yeah. So he's not going to say it wasn't a proper punch. Of course, it was a proper punch. And the giver of the punch is not going to say it wasn't the proper punch because by giving this punch, he's won the fight. So there's nothing to stop ringside, of course, betting, shouting the odds. And it's nothing to stop a single fighter doing a cross.
所以我正想问你这个。我是说，有什么能阻止他们中有人打假拳吗？没有。没错。那这该如何监管？还是说根本无法监管？根据他们比赛所遵循的1839年《伦敦规则》，你是不准单膝跪地的，除非你挨了真正有力的一拳。但你怎么去衡量什么才叫真正有力的一拳呢？唯一知道是否挨了有力一拳的人，只有出拳的人和挨打的人。如果挨打的人想要作弊——用行话来说这叫“假打”（cross），主动倒地认输，并且自己还买了自己输，他就能赚大钱。对啊。所以他才不会说那一拳不是有力的一拳呢。当然了，这就是有力的一拳。而出拳的人也不会说那不是有力的一拳，因为通过打出这一拳，他赢得了比赛。所以没有什么能阻止场边的人下注、大喊赔率。也没有什么能阻止某个拳手去打假拳。
Would a fighter like Tom Sayer, say, have a reputation as a man who was unlikely to do that? He did have that reputation, and that's why Bell's life wanted him to be reincarnated as a great, a great Englishman. But in truth, the last fight he had before Heenan was against them a novice, really. And apparently Tom had been seen dancing the night away the night before, and there was rumors of a cross that he was not going to be serious about it. He was going to, in the parlance, he was going to chuck it. But in the event, Tom didn't chuck it. fight was over in five minutes. So the crowd has gathered, all of these people, and it's about seven o'clock they come out.
像汤姆·赛尔斯这样的拳手，会有一种不太可能会做出这种事的声誉吗？他确实有那种声誉，这也是为什么《贝尔生活报》希望他能化身为一个伟大的、伟大的英国人。但事实上，他在对阵希南之前打的那场比赛，对手其实是个新手。显然，汤姆在前一天晚上还被人看到彻夜狂欢，而且有传言说这是一场假拳，他不会认真对待。用行话来说，他要“放弃”。但在最后关头，汤姆并没有放弃。比赛在五分钟内就结束了。所以人群聚集起来了，所有这些人，大约七点钟他们出发了。
Now, just to give us a sense of, you know, what they look like and stuff, you might think, because this is the 19th century or they don't take it very seriously, they haven't been properly training. They have been training. They've been training for months, haven't they, on the downs, Tom Sayers on the Sussex Downs, Heenan in Wiltshire. And what does a training routine involve for a 19th century boxer? Well, they went into training in February, so they had two, three months training.
现在，为了让我们对他们的外表之类的事情有个概念，你可能会想，因为这是19世纪，或者他们并不那么严肃对待，他们没有进行适当的训练。他们其实训练了。他们已经训练了几个月，对吧，在丘陵上，汤姆·赛尔斯在苏塞克斯丘陵，希南在威尔特郡。19世纪的拳击手的训练日常包含什么内容呢？好吧，他们在二月份就开始训练了，所以他们有两到三个月的训练期。
Tom, you notice, went on the downs with the racing fraternity and then went up the new market, again with the racing fraternity. There is a very old and honorable connection between riding, horse being, well, jockeying and fighting. Both sides have to keep their weight down, and jockeys knew how to do that in, fighters took that seriously. Tom's methods were exactly what a jocky of the time would do to keep fat off and keep muscles a bit like Tom's really nice and brisk and shiny. I'm interested to know what they do, whether it compares to my routine. It's about starving yourself, basically. It's about weights. It's about no sex.
你会发现，汤姆先是和赛马圈子的人一起去了丘陵，然后又去了纽马克特，同样是和赛马圈子的人在一起。骑马、赛马与打拳之间有着非常古老且光荣的联系。双方都必须控制体重，骑师们懂得如何做到这一点，而拳击手们对此非常认真。汤姆的方法完全符合当时骑师为了减脂和保持肌肉所做的事情，有点像汤姆那样，既漂亮又轻快又闪亮。我很想知道他们做些什么，这和我的日常生活相比如何。基本上就是让自己挨饿。这关乎体重。这关乎禁欲。
I don't know how that goes with you. No coffee No masturbation Hold on Rob Rob Rob I mean how do people know this Are they writing it down Are they training manuals
我不知道这和你合不合拍。没有咖啡，没有自慰。等等，罗伯，罗伯，罗伯，我是说，人们是怎么知道这些的？他们把它写下来了吗？有训练手册吗？
Yes there are There are training manuals How are they referring to it? Beastliness They call it masturbation It's a very old word I'm amazed I thought Victorians never talked about it
是的，有的。有训练手册。他们是怎么称呼它的？兽性。他们称之为自慰。这是一个非常古老的词。我很震惊，我还以为维多利亚时代的人从不谈论这个呢。
We're not talking about Victorians quote unquote here We're talking about the other side of Victorian life They took a massive pill before the fight a massive blue pill for constipation. But actually,
我们这里可不是在讨论所谓的维多利亚时代人。我们在讨论维多利亚时代生活的另一面。他们在赛前吞下了一颗巨大的药丸，一颗用于治疗便秘的巨大蓝色药丸。但实际上，
the thing is, Tom, they weren't doing anything that jockeys weren't doing. This was all understood and known and it wasn't unusual, actually. You know, the greatest ingest jockey of the century, Fred Archer, died
关键在于，汤姆，他们做的事情和骑师们做的事情没什么两样。这一切都是被理解和知晓的，其实并不罕见。你知道的，本世纪最伟大的英国骑师弗雷德·阿切尔，就是因为在训练日常中过于狂热而死于非命。
by just being overzealous in his training routines. Too many pills. Too many pills. Not enough food. They would make themselves sick. I mean, all the old tricks, which were only sadly,
吃了太多药丸。吃了太多药丸。食物摄入不足。他们会让自己呕吐。我是说，所有那些老把戏，我们现在（可悲的是）对此已经熟视无睹了。所以他们就这样坚持了几个月。希南却在哪里都定居不下来。他去哪里训练，当地警员都赶他走。所以他的营地从来没有稳定过。他一路穿过米德兰兹，最后在德比郡的一间牢房里过了一夜。那是因为当地警员出于爱国主义在试图阻止他训练吗？好吧，事情得回到我们刚才说的那个关于破坏治安的老问题上。
familiar with now. So they did that from a few months. Heenan couldn't settle anywhere. Everywhere he went to train, the constabulary told him to move on. So his camp was never settled. He went right through the Midlands and ended up in Derbyshire for a night in jail. And was that because the constabulary were being patriotic and trying to stop him from training? Well, the thing was you go back to this old thing about a breach of the peace.
无论他走到哪里，都会聚集起人群。而人群（你知道的）对他和他的美国随从并不总是那么迷人或温和。无论如何，他在德比附近的特伦特洛克训练营最终被捕了。他被保释了，保释金比他为比赛下注的实际保证金还要多。不管怎样，他坚持了下来。而且他已经习惯了。在美国也完全是一模一样。打拳就是这样一种偷偷摸摸的勾当。
Wherever he went, there was a crowd. And the crowd, you know, were not always charming or gentle with him and his American entourage. Anyway, he finally got arrested at his Trent Locke near Derby training camp. And he was put out on bail for more money than the actual steak he'd put down for the fight. Anyway, he kept going. And he was used to this. It was exactly the same in the United States. Fighting was such a hole in a corner affair.
你必须不断转移阵地。你必须时刻保持警惕，提防罗莎（警察）。有一件重要的事情，我必须把你带回比赛前的一天。1860年4月16日晚，希南出现在伦敦纳特·兰汉姆的酒馆——“寒武纪”酒馆。现在，他为什么要去兰汉姆的酒馆“寒武纪”呢？因为兰汉姆是唯一一个曾击败过赛尔斯的人。哦，对了。
You had to keep moving. You had to always be on, watch out for the Rosas. One important thing, I just have to take you one day back before the fight. On the night of the 16th of April, 1860, Heenan turned up at Nat Langham's pub in London, the Cambrian. Now, why did he go to Langham's pub, the Cambrian? Because Langham was the only man who'd ever beaten Sayers. Oh, right.
他来自莱斯特郡的欣克利。他是一个织布工，曾在1853年和赛尔斯打满全场并击败了他。所以这里面有点针锋相对的意思，你知道的，希南去找了那个击败过他（赛尔斯）的人。同理，唯一一个在希南唯一的比赛中击败过希南的人，约翰·莫里西，则站在了赛尔斯的阵营里。他们拥有内部消息。我很喜欢你对两人随从团队的描述。所以在比赛当天，他们见面了，握了手。希南的角落里挂着星条旗，
It came from Hinkley in Leicestershire. He was a framework nidder, and he'd taken Sears the full distance in 1853 and beaten him. So there's a bit of needle here that, you know, Heenan goes to the man who beat him. In the same sense, the one man to beat Heenan in his only fight, John Morrissey, he was in Sayers' corner. They've got inside information. I love the account you give of the entourages that both men have. So on the morning of the fight, they meet up, they shake hands. Hennon has the stars and stripes in his corner.
而赛尔斯，正如你所说，挂着奶油色背景的皇家旗帜，这太棒了。而且我认为这是英国拳击手应该重新引入的东西。但在7点29分，他们来到了中央。赛尔斯身后有两个助手，你形容他们板着脸就像板球里的守门员。也就是那些站在投球手后面的人。再加上他的经纪人、他的职业陪练（也是他的教练）。我最喜欢的细节是一个被称为“鸟人”的人，他穿着斗篷发出奇异的呼喊声。这个鸟人是怎么回事？
And Sayer, you say, has the royal standard on a cream background, which is tremendous. And I think is something that British boxers should reintroduce. But 729, they come to the middle. And Sayer has his two seconds behind him, who you describe as being like wicket keepers. So that's people who stand up to the bowling and cricket. Plus his manager, his professional walker, who is his trainer. And my favorite detail, someone called the bird man making queer halloo sounds in a cape. What's going on with the bird man?
我知道。他在干什么？他是谁？我知道。为什么现在的拳击手没有穿斗篷的鸟人和侏儒之类的人了？好吧，他在喊，喂，喂，喂。为什么？嗯，我觉得这肯定比希南的角落要强，那边有点无聊。
I know. What's he doing? Who is he? I know. And why do boxers not have bird men now in capes and dwarfs and things? Well, he's going, hello, hello, hello. Why? Well, I think it certainly beats Heenan's corner, which is a bit boring.
他带着他的叔叔、两个朋友，还有一个叫比利·穆利根的人，被《纽约时报》称为一个“神情极其坚定的人”。就我个人而言，我宁愿和吉米·霍尔顿还有鸟人在一起。所以比赛准备开始了。我们是不是应该在这个时候休息一下？气氛极度紧张，但当我们回来时，钟声就会敲响。比赛将正式开始，我们将拭目以待谁会获胜。在此之前，我们能做一件事吗？
He's got his uncle, two friends, and a man called Billy Mulligan, who the New York Times calls a very determined-looking fellow. Personally, I'd rather be with Jimmy Holden and the Birdman. So the fight is ready to begin. Should we take a break at this point? Tension is massive, but when we come back, the bell will sound. The fight will begin, and we will see who wins. Can we do one thing just before that?
我必须插一句，汤姆，那就是他们在真正开始比赛前要脱衣服，用行话来说就是“剥皮”，我的意思是他们脱掉了衬衫。这在比赛前非常重要，因为当你看到一个男人的身体时，你就能看出他们对即将发生的事有多么认真。没错。这里的关键是两人的身体状态都处于巅峰。所以汤姆·赛尔斯一直在身上涂抹醋，对吧？所以他被形容得像一块方方正正的胡桃木砖。所以他基本上是用醋给自己染了色。是这样的吗，罗伯？
I've got to put in, Tom, that it's what they do before they actually come to the fight is they strip, which in the parlance is they peel, by which I mean they take off their shirts. And that's really important before a fight, because when you see a man's body, then you see how serious they are about what's going to happen. Right. And the point here is both men are in superb condition. So Tom Sayers has been daubing himself with vinegar, hasn't he? So he's described us looking like a square brick of walnut. So he's kind of, he's dyed himself with vinegar. Is that right, Rob?
人们老信奉醋具有使皮肤变硬的特性。至于希南，他脸色极其苍白。当然了，他身高高出五英寸，体重重了两块半石头（约35磅），年轻了八九岁。《泰晤士报》在两个男人站在一起时形容他们俩就像“一匹马对上一只母鸡”。哇。难以置信的紧张气氛。那么谁会赢呢？
It was an old believer, skin-hardening properties of vinegar. And as for Heenan, he's incredibly pale. And of course, he's five inches taller, two and a half stones heavier, eight or nine years younger. The Times called it as the two men stood together as a horse to a hen. Wow. Unbelievable tension. So who will win?
是马还是母鸡？几分钟后回来揭晓答案。本集由世嘉与Creative Assembly为您呈现。为庆祝屡获殊荣的电子游戏《全面战争》诞生25周年，《全面战争：罗马2》与《全面战争：罗马：重制版》将在Steam上开启促销。在8月21日至9月4日期间，购买《罗马：重制版》可享75%（2.5折）优惠，购买《全面战争：罗马2》可享80%（2折）优惠。访问Steam并搜索Total War Rome即可立即购买。折扣仅在限定时间内有效。
The horse or the hen? Come back in a few minutes to find out. This episode is brought to you by Sega and Creative Assembly. To celebrate 25 years of creating award-winning video games, Total War, Rome 2 and Total War Rome Remastered will be on sale on Steam. Get Rome remastered at 75% off and get Total War Rome 2 for 80% off from the 21st of August to the 4th of September. Visit Steam and search for Total War Rome to buy now. The discount is valid for a limited time only.
须遵守相关条款与条件。你好，我是戈登·卡雷拉，国家安全记者。我是大卫·麦克洛斯基，前中情局分析师、现职小说家。我们一同主持另一档高吊节目：保密的余烬，在这里我们将为您带来间谍与机密世界里的最佳故事。我们刚刚推出了一档绝对精彩的新系列节目，讲述的是臭名昭著的哥伦比亚大毒枭巴勃罗·埃斯科巴，以及美国是如何花费数十年时间进行禁毒战争以将他的可卡因帝国绳之以法的。到1989年时，埃斯科巴已经是世界上第七大富豪，身家甚至超过了整个哥伦比亚国。
Terms and conditions apply. Hello, I'm Gordon Carrera, National Security Journalist. And I'm David McCloskey, former CIA analyst turned novelist. And together, we're the co-hosts of another Goalhanger show. The rest is classified, where we bring you the best stories from the world of spies and secrets. We have just released an absolutely cracking new series on the infamous Colombian drug lord Pablo Escobar, how the U.S. spent decades fighting a war on drugs to bring his cocaine empire to justice. By 1989, Escobar was the seventh richest man in the world, wealthier than the entire state of Colombia.
他是一个丈夫、一个父亲，也是世界上最令人闻风丧胆的毒品恐怖分子。但在他家乡麦德林穷人眼中，他却有点像个英雄。他修路、盖房、建足球场，对于一个饱受极端不平等且暴力的政治和法律体系折磨的国家来说，他几乎成了哥伦比亚的罗宾汉。在接下来的几周里，我们将带您深入了解搜捕埃斯科巴这一暗流汹涌的世界。通过部署寻找他的秘密军事单位成员的叙述，我们将揭示哥伦比亚和美国军队是如何通力合作，追踪这个控制了全球可卡因帝国的男人的。如果这听起来不错，我们很乐意在这集节目结尾为您播放一段精彩片段。
He was a husband, a father, and the most feared narco-terrorist in the world. But to the poor in his hometown of Medellin, he was kind of a hero. He built roads, houses, soccer fields, became almost a Colombian robin hood to a nation weary with a very unequal and violent political and legal system. Over the next few weeks, we'll take you deep inside the murky world of the hunt for Escobar. Using accounts from members of the secret military units deployed to find him, will reveal how Colombian and American forces work together to track down the man who controlled a global cocaine empire. If this sounds good, we'd love to clip for you at the end of this episode.
欢迎回到“历史的余烬”。我们正身处1860年4月17日汉普郡的一片田野里。人群已经聚集，
Welcome back to the rest is history. We are in a field in Hampshire on the 17th of April 1860. The crowd has assembled. the two men have peeled Sayers and Heenan. Rob, take us through what happens next. Well, they both walk to the center of the ring, so called. Of course, it's not a ring. It's actually a rectangle.
赛尔斯和希南这两个人已经“剥光了”。罗伯，带我们回顾一下接下来发生了什么。好吧，他们都走向所谓的擂台中央。当然，这不是一个环形擂台。它其实是一个长方形。
They go to the center of the ring, and Heenan says, Beautiful Morning to the man is about to try and kill him. And Tom says, want to bear on it? Which I loved. They go at it according to London Prize Ring rules. Just to be clear for listeners, these are not the rules that govern boxing in the way that they do now. So we'll come to how those laws evolve. These are London rules, which sounds like a kind of spy thriller, but it's a particular kind of fighting, isn't it?
他们走到擂台中央，希南对那个即将试图杀死他的人说：“天气真好啊。”而汤姆则说：“想不想拿这个打个赌？”我太喜欢这句了。他们按照伦敦奖金擂台规则展开对决。为了让听众清楚起见，这些并不是如今规范拳击运动的那种规则。所以我们稍后会讲到这些规则是如何演变的。这是伦敦规则，听起来像某种间谍惊悚片，但它是一种特定类型的格斗，对吧？
So what are London rules? What are the boxers allowed to do? So the first set of printed rules, Tom, are in the Bodleian Library in Oxford, and they were called Broughton's Rules, 1743. And London rules were in the evolution of Broughton's rules of 1743. Basically, there were no weight categories. So there was no heavyweights, lightweights, middle weights. They were just matches. And the match was anybody who was willing to put their money up behind a man,
那么什么是伦敦规则呢？拳手们被允许做什么？第一套印刷出来的规则，汤姆，保存在牛津大学的博德利图书馆里，被称为“布劳顿规则”，即1743年的规则。而伦敦规则就是在1743年布劳顿规则上演变而来的。基本上，当时没有重量级别。所以没有重量级、轻量级、中量级之分。只有比赛。而比赛就是任何愿意把钱押在一个人身上、
fighting another man. So clearly, Sayas was 5'8 and 11 stone. He was actually a middleweight. But he couldn't get middleweights to fight him. Or more accurately, they couldn't get. people to back them to fight him. So he's fighting, it's a middleweight fighting a heavyweight because London rules have no weight categories. The second thing is there's no fixed rounds. The round ends when one man drops to one knee and he can do that at any point and get a 30 second
去对抗另一个人的人之间的对决。很显然，赛尔斯身高5英尺8英寸（约173厘米），体重11英石（约70公斤）。他其实是个中量级。但他找不到中量级来跟他打。或者更准确地说，他们找不到人来下注支持中量级跟他打。所以他在打一场中量级对重量级的比赛，因为伦敦规则没有重量级别。第二点是没有固定的回合。当一个人单膝跪地时，回合就结束了，他可以在任何时候这样做，并获得30秒的喘息时间。
breather. But there aren't points. So it doesn't, you know, it doesn't penalise him. There's no points in London rules. You just have to really reduce a man to such a state that he can't come to scratch, even though he's had his 30-second breather. There was less force in this because they were bare knuckle. And in addition to hitting with your bare hand, you could throw, you could wrestle. But what you couldn't do, this is where London rules civilized things a bit, you couldn't bite, you couldn't butt, you couldn't kick, you couldn't gouge, you couldn't strangle, and, of course, you couldn't hit below the waist.
但没有积分。所以，你知道的，它不会因此扣分。伦敦规则里没有积分。你真的必须把一个人折磨到无法来到划痕标记处的状态，哪怕他已经享受了30秒的喘息时间。由于这是赤手空拳，这里的打击力度较小。除了用赤手空拳击打外，你还可以投掷、摔跤。但你不能做的是——这也是伦敦规则让事情稍微文明一点的地方——你不能咬人、不能用头撞、不能踢人、不能用手指抠挖（眼睛）、不能锁喉，当然了，你不能击打腰部以下。
And you say in your book that prize fighters also shave themselves. So like the Macedonians, they shave off their beards so that their opponents can't grab them by their beards. Yes, if you are in an exchange, which is part boxing and part wrestling, it doesn't help to have long hair or beard. In Mendoza's famous fight, I think it was 1795 with John Jackson, gentleman John Jackson, Jackson ended the fight by swinging him round by his hair. So Mendoza's long hair didn't do him proud on that occasion. So you could always tell a fighter by his cropped hair and Krugert knows. That's the way to do it.
你在书里提到，奖金拳手们还会刮体毛。就像马其顿人一样，他们会刮掉胡子，这样对手就抓不住他们的胡子了。是的，如果你处于一场既有拳击又有摔跤的缠斗中，留长发或胡子可帮不上忙。在门多萨（Mendoza）那场著名的比赛中——我想那是1795年对阵约翰·杰克逊，绅士约翰·杰克逊——杰克逊通过抓着门多萨的头发把他转圈甩来结束了比赛。所以门多萨的长发在那次并没有为他争光。因此，你总是可以通过修剪过的头发和克鲁格特（Krugert）标志来识别一个拳手。这才是正确的方法。
And they also have spiked boots, is that right? Yeah. The thing is, it's really, given that the rosas are always onto you or are liable to be onto you, fights can start in one county. end in another one because the two fighters would actually be on the run. So it's quite obvious that you couldn't fight indoors. It was just too risky. So most fights were outside where if the police turned up, you could run for it. So the boots were spiked. Your head was held back. Your fists were low, but up. Your feet were turned out. In other words, you were well turned out. And you would
而且他们还穿着带钉的靴子，是这样吗？是的。问题在于，鉴于罗莎（警察）随时都在盯着你，或者随时可能盯上你，比赛经常在一个郡开始，在另一个郡结束，因为两个拳手实际上是在逃亡中。所以很显然，你不可能在室内打比赛。那太冒险了。因此，大多数比赛都在室外进行，如果警察出现，你可以拔腿就跑。所以靴子的鞋底是带钉的。你的头要往后仰。你的拳头要放低但随时准备出击。你的双脚要向外撇开。换句话说，你的姿态要舒展。然后你会
Bob and Weave and Duck until first punch was landed. And the first punch in this fight actually went to the old pro, Sayers, who landed one square on Heenan's nose. Knobbing, it was called, in the parlance. Knobbing in the parlance and applause in the crowd. So a knobbing, knobbing is when you hit someone on the nose? Flat on the nose, yeah. and you draw, it was never called blood, of course, it was always called Ruby or Clarit.
左右摇晃、闪躲，直到第一记重拳落地。而这场比赛的第一记重拳实际上落在了老老练的赛尔斯身上，他一拳结结实实地打在了希南的鼻子正中央。行话里把这叫“敲鼻头”（knobbing）。行话里叫“敲鼻头”，引来人群一片喝彩。所以，“敲鼻头”，敲鼻头就是当你想打某人鼻子的时候？正中鼻子，对吧。 and you draw，这里从来不叫出血，当然了，它总是被称为“红宝石”（Ruby）或“克雷特”（Clarit，波尔多红酒）。
So you knob to draw Ruby. At that point, Heenan grabbed Sayers by the neck, but Sayers punched his way out of it, and apparently both men felt at the floor laughing, round one over. And there's no limit on the number of rounds, is that right? So if they want to fight for 10, 20, 30, this case, 40 plus rounds, they can because looking at Sayers' record, he knows that this could go on for a long time because he has had bouts that have lasted two hours, two and a half hours, I mean, mind-boggling, how exhausting and unbelievably dangerous, that must be.
所以你通过敲鼻头来打出“红宝石”。就在那时，希南抓住赛尔斯的脖子，但赛尔斯出拳挣脱了，显然两个人都大笑着倒在了地板上，第一回合结束。而且回合数没有限制，对吧？所以如果他们想打10个、20个、30个回合，在这个案例中是40多个回合，他们完全可以，因为看看赛尔斯的记录，他知道这可能会持续很长时间，因为他曾有过持续两个小时、两个半小时的比赛。我的天，这是多么令人头皮发麻、精疲力竭且难以置信的危险啊。
Well, it is dangerous, of course. They're aiming for your head, your temple, below your ear. they're trying to blind you with hits, jabbing. I mean, gouging's out, but jabbing's in, jabbing to the eyes, or peg to the stomach, as it was called, or they want to throw you and land heavily on you, or they want to fib, which means getting your head under one arm and punching away in the face with the other. And that was called having a suit enchancery. Is that really what they call that? Yeah, suit and chancery is holding your head under my arm, let's put it that way, and I hit you with my right hand. With your British muscle.
嗯，这确实很危险，当然了。他们的目标是你的头部、太阳穴、耳朵下方。他们试图通过击打、刺拳来让你眼花缭乱。我是说，抠挖眼睛是不行的，但刺拳是可以的，用刺拳攻击眼睛，或者像人们所说的那样用直拳攻击胃部，或者他们想把你摔倒并重重地压在你身上，或者他们想用“封喉锁”（fib），这意味着把你的头夹在胳膊底下，用另一只手往脸上猛击。这被称为“陷入大法官裁判所”（having a suit in chancery）。这真的是他们对那种姿势的称呼吗？对，陷入大法官裁判所就是把你的头夹在我的胳膊底下，这么说吧，然后我用右手打你。用你那充满英国肌肉的手臂。
Oh, there's a cross buttock, how about that one, where you throw a man over your buttock in effect, and then you land on him very heavily. Right. Actually, Dom, this isn't, this isn't you. I don't know about you guys, but this is how schoolboys fought when I was a kid. It was all head and chancery and crossbuttock. Yeah. Not that much punching, actually. It was more about wrestling someone down and getting them to say, getting them to say sorry. Yeah. Headlocks. It's all about headlocks, isn't it?
哦，还有一个跨腰摔，那个怎么样，就是实际上把一个人从你腰上扔过去，然后狠狠地压在他身上。对。其实，多姆，这不是，这不是你。我不知道你们怎么样，但这就是我小时候男孩子们打架的方式。全都是锁头箍颈和跨腰摔。是的。其实没那么多拳击。更多的是把人摔倒在地，让人家说，让人家说对不起。是的。锁喉。全都是锁喉，对吧？
So essentially, you win the match by getting someone flat on the ground. But to do that, you have to make his knuckles have to be broken. His face, you know, maybe his eyes so swollen that he can't actually see. And as Dominic says, that might take, well, as it does, in this case, it takes what, two hours, two and a half hours? Yeah, you have to make him incapable. basically and he has to be able to make it to the scratch mark himself not carried there was a terrible case of manslaughter where a man was carried to the scratch by his seconds where he was basically beaten to death the thing is though you've got to just remember this these fights are not as horrible and violent as they might sound because the new queensbury
所以本质上，你必须把对手打得平趴在地上才算赢得比赛。但要做到这一点，你得把他的指关节打折。他的脸，你知道的，也许眼睛肿得根本看不见。正如多米尼克所说，这可能需要，嗯，像这次一样，花了大概多久，两小时，两个半小时？对，你基本上得让他失去行动能力，而且他必须自己走到起跑线（划痕线）那里，而不是被人扛过去。曾经有一个可怕的过失杀人案件，一个男人被他的助阵员扛到了起跑线上，当时他基本上已经被活活打死了。不过关键是，你必须记住这一点：这些比赛并不像听起来那么可怕和暴力，因为新的昆斯伯里
rules ring was in certain ways more violent because because you had the 10th second rule on a knockout. So fighters were looking to hit your head so hard that your brain would hit your skull and cause concussion. That's what a CO is. And all the great fighters who followed Heenan and Sayers were CO specialists. And in a 10 second count over a three-minute round,
规则拳击台在某些方面其实更加暴力，因为当时有击倒后十秒读秒的规则。所以拳击手们都试图猛击你的头部，让你的大脑撞击头骨并导致脑震荡。这就是KO的意思。所有在希南和赛尔斯之后名垂青史的伟大拳击手都是KO专家。而在三分钟一个回合内的十秒读秒期间，
there was nowhere to hide. I think it was Ali who said, you know, you can run, but you can't hide. In the old ring, if you were getting tired or you were hurt, you would just go down on a knee, pretend you'd been hit. But in the modern ring, you just had to keep going until such time as the three minutes were up. You also make the point, don't you, the difference between this fight, let's say, the Sayas Heenan fight and a modern fight. Because they're not wearing gloves, they are hurting their hands every time they land. a punch, which counterintuitively, to me, because I think of bare-knuckle boxing with kind of, with horror, but actually the punches are much, they're not exactly pulling their
根本无处可藏。我想是阿里说过，你知道，你可以跑，但你无处可藏。在旧拳台里，如果你累了或者受伤了，你只要单膝跪地，假装被击中就行了。但在现代拳击台里，你只能硬挺着，直到三分钟结束。你还指出了这一点，不是吗？这场比赛（比如说赛尔斯与希南之战）与现代比赛的区别。因为他们不戴手套，每次出拳都会伤到自己的手，这对我来说反直觉，因为我对赤拳格斗总是带着某种恐惧，但实际上他们的出拳要重得多——也不能说他们没有全力出拳，
punches, where you are, if your knuckles are bleeding. Well, this is the point, that your punch is perhaps not carrying the force. I mean, you've already made this point, rather that it's not carrying the force that it would in the modern ring, is that right? Yeah, that's what, I've never seen a bare-knuckle fight, and I don't want to, but I've read, I've read about this. Apparently, the old PR prize ring punch was very direct and very straight. It couldn't hit you from the side because then you would probably break some fingers.
只要你的指关节在流血。嗯，关键就在这里，你的出拳或许没有那么大的威力。我的意思是，你之前已经提出过这个观点了，或者说它没有现代拳击台里那种摧枯拉朽的力量，是这样吗？是的，就是这样——我从未看过赤拳格斗，也不想看，但我读过、读过这方面的资料。显然，老普赖兹奖金拳台（PR prize ring）的出拳非常直接且笔直。你不能从侧面挥拳，因为那样你可能会骨折几根手指。
So it was a fib, it was short and sharp and in the face or in the eyes. A jab, it was a jab rather than a knockout swing. The swing really could break your hand. So I'm sure that by this point, listeners will be dying to know who wins. Well, it's not clear. That's the problem. We go 42 rounds, more or less in the manner we've been discussing. There's two big things happen in the 42 rounds.
所以这只是一种试探，短促而锐利，直奔面部或眼睛。这是一记刺拳，而不是一记能KO的重摆拳。挥拳确实会弄断你的手。所以我敢肯定，听到这里，听众们一定急于知道到底谁赢了。嗯，结果并不明朗。这就是问题所在。我们打了42个回合，大致就是我们刚才讨论的那种方式。这42个回合中发生了两件大事。
The first thing is Sayers loses the use of his right arm. He thinks it's broken. The crowd thinks it's broken. It turns out not to be broken, but it's certainly out of action. So we've got to imagine Sayers now holding the arm across his chest and basically keeping out of Hennon's grab and trying to jab him in the eye. By around 37, the second thing happens,
第一件事是赛尔斯失去了右臂的使用权。他自己觉得断了，观众也觉得断了。结果证明没断，但确实已经无法动用了。所以我们可以想象一下，赛尔斯现在把那只胳膊横在胸前，基本上是在躲避希南的抓抱，并试图用刺拳戳他的眼睛。到了第37回合左右，第二件事发生了，
Heenan by now is pretty much blinded by the jabbing, and he grabs, say as he grabs him, and pulls him to the ropes where he wraps his rope around his neck and basically 195 pounds leans on the rope, which is on the neck. Now, believe it or not, this is actually unlawful according to London rules.
此时的希南已经被刺拳打得几乎双目失明，他抓住了赛尔斯，一把将他拉到围绳边，用围绳套住他的脖子，基本上是用195磅的体重压在勒住脖子的围绳上。现在，信不信由你，根据伦敦规则，这其实是犯规的。
I was wondering. You're not allowed to murder your opponent in the ring. And it's at this point that the crowd surge into the ring and basically the fight stops. There are rumours that
我就知道。你不能在拳击台上谋杀你的对手。也就是在这个时候，观众一拥而上冲进拳击台，比赛基本上就此中断。有传言称，
also at this point, Morrissey, who you remember is the man who stopped Heenan in New York, Morrissey jumps in and cuts the ropes. So that's not going to happen again. There's chaos in the ring.
也正是在这个时候，莫里斯——大家还记得吧，就是曾在纽约阻止过希南的那个人——跳进台内把围绳给割断了。这样这种事就不会再发生了。拳击台上乱成一团。
The police finally move in to stop murder. And both fighters basically leg it across the field. But it's amazing, they're in a condition to leg it. I was about to say, one man's got no arm. The other man is blind. The other one's just been strangled by a rope. They're presumably dripping with Ruby and exhausted. Yes, Ruby everywhere.
警方终于介入以制止谋杀。两个拳击手基本上都撒腿跑过了场地。但令人惊奇的是，他们竟然还有体力逃跑。我正想说，一个人连一条胳膊都废了，另一个人是个瞎子，还有一个人刚刚被绳子勒过。他们身上大概都血淋淋的筋疲力尽。是的，到处都是血。
Well, Heenan has to be led by the hand as he legs it across the field because he can't really see. And Sayers is, actually Sayers in a decent condition apart from his arm, which is swelling alarmingly. They hopped back to London. Heenan is put to bed for two days. But not our Tom. Our Tom's up the next morning at Owen Swift asking for his money because he thinks he's won it. On what basis does he think he's won it?
嗯，希南横穿场地时不得不靠人拉着手带过去，因为他根本看不清路。而赛尔斯其实状况还算可以，除了那只肿得吓人的胳膊。他们一瘸一拐地回到了伦敦。希南卧床休息了两天。但我们的汤姆可没有。我们的汤姆第二天一大早就去找欧文·斯威夫特要钱，因为他觉得自己赢了。他凭什么觉得自己赢了？
Because he's just been strangled with by a rope. Disqualification. disqualification for the American, surely, Tom. It's a difficult one, isn't it? I mean, you're fighting someone who's just wandering around the ring like a zombie, can't see, and you're peppering him until he finally grabs you. I mean, the whole thing is a tortured farce. And in real terms, it's effectively the end of the prize ring.
因为他刚刚被绳子勒过啊。取消资格！那个美国人肯定被取消资格了，汤姆。这很难说，不是吗？我的意思是，你在和一个像僵尸一样在擂台里晃悠、什么也看不见的人打架，你不断地攻击他，直到他最终抓住你。我的意思是，整件事简直就是一场饱受折磨的闹剧。从实际意义上讲，它实际上标志着普赖兹奖金拳击时代的终结。
Am I not right in saying that for the press on both sides of the Atlantic, they say, well, like, and I'm quoting from your chapter, Sportswriters on both sides of the Atlantic were already busy turning a nasty case of common assault into a heroic draw between two great sporting nations. So there's obviously been a lot of national pride riding on this. And basically, both papers on both sides of the Atlantic are happy to say, what a tremendous occasion this was reflects greatly to, you know, redounds to the credit of both great Anglo-Saxon nations. Hurrah for Britain and America. And they're both equally, they're both champions. Is that basically the long and short of it?
我说得没错吧？当时大西洋两岸的媒体都在说，嗯，就像——我引用你书中的话：“大西洋两岸的体育记者们已经忙着把一桩恶劣的普通袭击案，包装成两个伟大体育国度之间一场英雄式的平局。”所以这显然倾注了大量的民族自豪感。基本上，大西洋两岸的报纸都很高兴地宣称，这是一场多么了不起的盛事，这极大地为，你知道的，两个伟大的盎格鲁-撒克逊国家增光添彩。为英国和美国欢呼吧。而且他们两边都同样是冠军。简而言之，差不多就是这个意思吗？
Yeah, absolutely, that's right. They started the fight, the press started the fight. It's in the London and New York Press once a week for a whole year before it takes place. And then it's never out of the press afterwards. And the whole point is both men get a replica belt, both men get a reception at the Alhambra Theatre in London, where they walk around the stage arm and arm. Hennon having to stoop a little for his diminutive opponent with his white cane. And these awful sickly speeches are made on behalf of two proud fighting nations.
是的，完全正确，就是这样。他们挑起了这场比赛，媒体挑起了这场比赛。在比赛举行前整整一年里，伦敦和纽约的报纸每周都会报道一次。之后更是长年累月地占据报端。最关键的是，两个人都得到了一条复制版的金腰带，都在伦敦阿罕布拉剧院受到了欢迎，他们手挽着手走上舞台。希南不得不为了他那身材矮小的对手稍微弯下腰，手里还拿着一根白手杖。为了这两个骄傲的战斗民族，发表了一番肉麻至极的矫情演讲。
And what about the bettors? I mean, how does that divvied out? Well, we don't know about the betting, Tom, because it's so unofficial. But the point about boxing, because there's only two men, the odds are all. was short. So you're not going to get massive returns. It was two to one when they started. It was seven to four the day before. It was two to one on the day. We don't know about that. They might have even bet against themselves. We never know these things. Right. The stake money was what they were both wanting. And I have to confess, I don't actually know what happened to that.
那赌徒们呢？我是说，这钱是怎么分账的？嗯，我们不清楚赌博的事，汤姆，因为这太非官方了。但关于拳击的关键在于，因为只有两个人，赔率一直都很低。所以你不会获得巨额回报。比赛开始时是二比一，前一天是七比四，当天是二比一。我们对这些并不了解。他们甚至可能压根就没下注。我们永远搞不清这些事情。好吧。赌金才是他们两人都想要的。而且我得承认，我其实并不知道那笔钱后来怎么处理了。
Before we talk about what it all means, the two men themselves, they are forever, I mean, neither of them live very long after the fight, do they? They are both. They are both. Both celebrities, and they're linked in the popular imagination, aren't they? They're sort of seen as brothers in arms. Tom has a succession of kind of benefits and basically pantomime clown appearances at which Heenan will sometimes put in a kind of, you know, he'll turn up as a sort of special guest star. That's a long tradition, isn't it? Frank Bruno as Widow Twanky or whatever he was playing in the 90s.
在我们谈论这一切意味着什么之前，这两个人本身，他们永远——我的意思是，两人在比赛结束后都没活多久，对吧？他们都是。他们都是名人，并且在公众的想象中被紧紧联系在一起，不是吗？他们被视为某种患难与共的兄弟。汤姆接连参加了各种慈善义演，基本上就是扮演滑稽剧中的小丑，而希南有时也会以某种，你知道的，以某种特别嘉宾的身份出场。这是一个悠久的传统，对吧？就像弗兰克·布鲁诺在90年代扮演的“双胞胎寡妇特万基”或其他什么角色。
All these men knew about tights and makeup. but there's no doubt about it. And the Britannia Theatre in Hoxton was London's biggest and Dickens' favourite. Dickens says, going to the Britannia's like going to an Italian opera. Nothing interesting happening on the stage. It's all off the stage where it's happening. And Tom becomes a fixture at the Britannia with his two mules,
所有这些人都对紧身衣和化妆了如指掌。但毫无疑问，位于霍克斯顿的布列塔尼亚剧院是伦敦最大也是狄更斯最喜欢的剧院。狄更斯说，去布列塔尼亚剧院就像去听一场意大利歌剧。舞台上没什么有趣的事发生，所有精彩的戏码都在台下上演。而汤姆成了布列塔尼亚剧院的常客，带着他的两头骡子，
Barney and Pete. He's in loads of pantomimes. I mean, his opponent, Heenan, married the great star, American, star, a kind of 19th century Barbara Streisland, Ada Mencken. He married her. She was a real big theatre star, whereas Tom comes from a much different tradition. The nearest he ever got to a woman and the theatre was when his wife hit him in the face outside the Britannia. So the two very different men, but they both are theatrical stars, they're ornaments to the theatre. Tom goes on the stage and Heenan has two more fights, which he loses.
巴尼和皮特。他参演了大量的滑稽哑剧。我的意思是，他的对手希南，娶了美国伟大的巨星、19世纪的芭芭拉·史翠珊式的明星——艾达·门肯。他娶了她。她是个真正的大剧院明星，而汤姆则来自截然不同的传统。他离女人和剧院最近的一次，是他妻子在布列塔尼亚剧院外面扇了他一巴掌。所以这是两个截然不同的人，但他们都是戏剧界的明星，是剧院的装饰品。汤姆继续上台表演，而希南又打了两场比赛，结果都输了。
The fight with Tom is considered a draw. So poor old Heenan never actually manages to win one. They both die aged 38, 39 of TB. I don't think their lifestyles were particularly wonderful. Tom got £3,000 actually raised by Lloyds, and the Houses of Parliament. So as a true English hero is going to be all right for money. But he took all that money and put it into a travelling circus in the US.
与汤姆的那场比赛被判定为平局。所以可怜的希南实际上从未真正赢过一场。两人都在38、39岁时死于肺结核。我并不认为他们的生活方式有多么美好。汤姆从劳埃德保险公司和议会那里筹集到了3,000英镑。所以作为一个真正的英国英雄，他的钱财是没有问题了。但他把所有的钱都投进美国的一个巡回马戏团里去了。
But he took a very bad year to do it. He did in 1862. So he couldn't travel around by a civil war was raging. He's in Hennon's Corner in 1863, in Hennon's fight with Tom King, which was probably a cross. By 1864, he's a diabetic. and an alcoholic, living with his sister in Camden. And he dies in November, 1865, and Camden High Street of TB.
但他选择了一个非常糟糕的年份来做这件事。那是1862年。当时南北战争正酣，他根本无法四处巡演。1863年，他在希南的角落里，见证了希南与汤姆·金的比赛，那可能是一场打假拳。到了1864年，他已经是一个患有糖尿病和酗酒的病人，和姐姐住在卡姆登。1865年11月，他在卡姆登高街死于肺结核。
And is he remembered? I mean, is his death greeted with mourning and parades? There's a massive funeral. Massive funeral, isn't there, Rob? Yes, I mean, the fight of the century was in 1860. 1865 was called the funeral of the year. Something between, they reckon about 10,000 people followed the casket. Is his dog there?
那人们还记得他吗？我是说，他的死伴随着哀悼和游行吗？有一场盛大的葬礼。盛大的葬礼，不是吗，罗布？是的，我的意思是，世纪之战是在1860年。1865年则被称为年度葬礼。据估计，大约有1万多人护送着灵柩。他的狗也在那里吗？
Lion? Yes, Lion, the dog. I am Tom Sayer's dog. Who's dog are you? It's an invitation to fight, really, isn't it? Yeah, it really is. His dog is there, and his pony, and his phaeton. And what about his mules?
狮子？是的，那只名叫“狮子”的狗。我是汤姆·赛尔斯的狗。你是谁的狗？这其实是一个约战的暗号，对吧？是的，确实如此。他的狗出席了，还有他的小马和四轮马车。那他的骡子呢？
You just threw that out. Where are these mules come from? And what about the bird man? I think they put the bird man in a box. The mules were not at the funeral, although he did have 16 horses, but they were all sold at auction after the funeral. So Lyon went for 30 pounds to a North London publican. Tom Cribb's belt, which had been presented to Tom at his...
你刚才随口提到了这个。这些骡子是从哪来的？还有那个鸟人呢？我想他们把鸟人装进一个箱子里了吧。骡子并没有出现在葬礼上，尽管他确实有16匹马，但这些马都在葬礼后被拍卖了。所以“狮子”以30英镑的价格卖给了一位北伦敦的酒馆老板。汤姆·克里布的金腰带，那是曾颁发给汤姆的……
So Tom Cribb is the great... I mean, he's the archetype of a British boxer, isn't he? We could do a whole programme on Cribb. Cribb is John Bull, and John Bull is William Cobbert, and William Cobbit is Tom Crib. I mean, they are the great figures of the Napoleonic period. Well, Tom's got his belt, his silver belt. They sell that for 55 pound, 10 shillings. Tom's mule goes for 13 pounds, and his mayor, a Duncob, for 23 pounds.
所以汤姆·克里布是伟大的……我的意思是，他是英国拳击手的原型，对吧？我们可以专门做一整期节目来聊聊克里布。克里布就是约翰牛，约翰牛就是威廉·科贝特，而威廉·科贝特就是汤姆·克里布。我的意思是，他们是拿破仑时代伟大的代表人物。好吧，汤姆有他的腰带，他的银腰带。他们把它以55英镑10先令的价格卖掉了。汤姆的骡子卖了13英镑，他的母马——一头邓科布马——卖了23英镑。
That's after the funeral. There's a fight at Highgate Cemetery Gates when it seemed that the 10,000 people weren't all going to be allowed in it once. But apparently, once the fight was over, it was very, very seemly and quite respectable. Apparently, his wife went. Nat Langham, his Victor of 1853. He was there dressed in a red Garibaldi shirt. And of course, wonderfully, the spectator called the whole thing disgusting. This is the sport of harpies and capitalists.
那是葬礼之后的事了。当1万名观众似乎无法同时被允许进入时，海格特公墓大门外还发生了一场混战。但显然，一旦冲突结束，一切就变得非常得体且相当体面。据说他的妻子也去了。纳特·兰厄姆，1853年汤姆的手下败将，也身穿红色加里波第衬衫出席了。当然，妙趣横生的是，《旁观者》杂志称整件事“令人作呕”。这就是“鹰身女妖和资本家们的运动”。
Oh, my word. Well, I mean, you could say it's maybe not wrong. And what about Heenan? Heenan died 1873 in Wyoming. Yeah. And again, presumably there's been a lot of hard drinking, a lot of brawling. He hasn't led the healthiest, most slubriest of lives. Mind you, a lot of people die of TP in the 19th century. It's the great killer, particularly, I mean, you know, of writers,
哦，天哪。好吧，我的意思是，你也可以说这并非完全不对。那希南呢？希南于1873年在怀俄明州去世。是的。同样，可以想见，其中伴随着大量的酗酒和斗殴。他的生活过得并不健康，也谈不上多么滋润。不过话又说回来，19世纪有很多人死于肺结核。这是个巨大的杀手，尤其是对——你知道的——作家、诗人和拳击手而言。所以我想问题是，这一切意味着什么？那么，所有这一切，作为一个历史学家，你写了很多关于工人阶级生活、英国特色以及所有这些方面的东西，这说明了什么？因为你在书里讨论这个章节的标题很简单，就叫“韧性”（Bottom）。英国人有“韧性”，而他们更是其中的佼佼者。所以你所说的“韧性”是什么意思？嗯，他们所说的意思是承受与反击的能力，尤其是承受打击的能力。所以你可以把它比作英国军队在面对骑兵进攻时结成的方阵。最著名的就是滑铁卢战役。而你提到，拳击手经常被比作方阵中的英国士兵。
poets, and it seems fighters. So I guess the question is, what does it mean? So what does all this, as a historian, you've written lots about working class life and about Englishness and all these kinds of things? What does this tell us? Because the chapter in which you, in the book, in which you discuss it. It's called simply bottom. Englishmen had bottom and par excellence had bottom. So what do you mean by that? Well, what they meant by it was the ability to give and take, particularly take punishment. So you compare it to the square that the British army forms when being attacked by cavalry. So famously it happens at the Battle of Waterloo. And the boxer, you say, is often compared to the British soldier in a square.
我认为它的意思是，汤姆，拳击和所有体育运动一样，深深植根于我们的意识、我们的想象力，以及我们关于“我们是谁”的自我叙事中。这可以被描述为平民版本的国家历史。它是平民版本的荣誉，一种关于当关键时刻来临、英国人能够展现自我价值的荣誉。它无处不在，显而易见却又不令人意外地渗透到了军队及其自我认知中。注意，不是骑兵——那是截然不同的战斗方式，而是步兵团。我不知道你对军事历史了解多少，但步兵团其实只有一个任务，那就是迎着地狱般的枪林弹雨向前挺进。当他们决定停下、展开军旗并开火时，他们所能展现的其实只有斯多葛主义或“韧性”。“韧性”本质上是平民化的一种斯多葛主义。而方阵就是这种精神的写照。
I think what it means, Tom, boxing, like all sports, goes very deep into our consciousness, into our imagination, into the stories we tell ourselves about who we are. And this might be described as the plebeian version of national history. It's the plebeian version of honour, the honour fight that when it comes, comes to it, the English can give an account of themselves. And it spreads everywhere, obviously,
英国的威灵顿公国认为，结成方阵是一种绝妙的战术，这样你就可以向周围的人持续开火。不幸的是，敌人也非常喜欢英国人的方阵，因为他们只需面对一个红色的方阵，就可以把能倾泻的一切火力都砸向它。这就是给你的其中一层含义，多姆，一层含义。但我在阅读你的章节时还发现了一个引人入胜的现象：正当拳击手被等同于约翰牛、英国方阵以及某种特定的英国性时，也有一些表现得更加矛盾的人物，他们同样被奉为绅士。比如你提到的留着长发、四处受挫的丹尼尔·门多萨，他是犹太人；还有曾身为奴隶的黑人美国人比尔·里士满，他同样因在擂台上的功绩而被尊为绅士。我的意思是，如果你不是那种纯粹的英国自耕农，成为一名伟大的拳击手是否会赋予你一种英国绅士的荣誉身份？这就是正在发生的事情吗？差不多就是这样。我认为拳击是一个兄弟会。我觉得过去是，现在也是。我认为其中包含着一种尊重、骄傲以及对彼此力量的认可。我的意思是，拳击手们当然会在赛前互相贬低，但在赛后却极其罕见。就像这场比赛一样？就像这场比赛一样。你知道的，威灵顿曾把他的部队形容为“阴郁而沉默寡言”。英国步兵以安静闻名。他们会保持安静，而法国人则带着所有的冲劲冲锋，他们以在进攻时大喊大叫而闻名，
and not surprisingly, it seeps into the army and its sense of itself. Not the cavalry, note, which is a very different kind of fighting, but the regiments of the line. I don't know how much military history you know, but the regiments of the line had only one job, really, and that was to walk forward into hell, really. And when they decided to stop, and unfurled their colours and fire, all they could show really was stoicism or bottom. Bottoms are really a plebeian form of stoicism. And the square was an example of that.
他们同样勇敢。但那是截然不同的风格。看起来门多萨、里士满和曾经是美国黑奴的莫利纽克斯在这个国家都大受欢迎。里士满曾是乔治四世加冕典礼上的男侍童。他和克里布曾一起在加冕典礼的门口维持秩序，担任保镖，并穿着男侍童的制服。这里面存在着一种兄弟会的情谊。现在，当然，我并不是说没有种族主义。当然有种族主义，针对他们的种族主义是存在的，但出于显而易见的原因，从未当着他们的面。现在，我知道我们的时间快不够了，汤姆想问关于——汤姆提到了昆斯伯里侯爵，但在我们谈到那个之前，还有一个简短的问题。这一切的政治意义是什么？因为你的书是关于体育与自由的，你在这一章里有一句话：“只有托利党人才能成为真正的运动员。只有托利党人拥有韧性。”这是一种托利党式的英国吗？某种传统的、抗拒改良、抗拒改革的英国？你知道的，拳击一直受到你所谓的“好人”（do-gooders）的批评，并且有一种普遍的看法。喜欢它的人似乎觉得，正如你所说，它是一种历史在底下的延续，一种对传统的感知，诸如此类。这让我想起了杰科·麦卡科。那只战斗的猴子。战斗的猴子，同样浑身是血。人们也曾对动物互相残杀至死感到不安。但同样，关于好人们试图将其净化。人道主义者迪克，汤姆，正如你可能记得的那样，曾试图彻底取缔它。所以，罗布，你关于这是一种托利主义的说法，是一个严肃的观点吗？是的，这是一个严肃的观点。
The British Wellington considered it a marvellous tactic to form a square where you could fire continuously at those around you. Unfortunately, enemies loved the British square because they just had a red square to pour everything they could into it. There's one meaning for you, Dom, one meaning. But what I also found fascinating reading your chapter was that even as the boxer is being equated
这个观点的问题在于，尽管它是严肃的，但我们永远不知道托利主义到底是什么。因为根据定义，它是非意识形态的，无法被明确定义，并且无休止地适应着现状。只有在这个意义上，我们才知道它在任何特定时刻是什么。但鉴于后来发生的事情——比如说克里布之后，英国出现了一场旨在使民众文明化的宏大运动。这场运动广义上说是自由主义的，广义上说是大都市式的，广义上说是对那些被认为粗俗、愚蠢和白痴的人居高临下的。随着时间的推移，托利主义针对这一点摆出了自己的立场。它决定自己不是那种政治。
with John Bull, with the British Square, with a particular idea of Englishness, there are also figures who are more ambivalent, who are also being enshrined as gentlemen. So you mentioned Daniel Mendoza with his long hair who gets tossed around. he's Jewish and there's a former slave, a black American, Bill Richmond, who likewise is hailed as a gentleman for his feats in the ring. I mean, does being a great boxer give you a kind
它是另一种政治。所以，正如你从书中所知，我们在整个世纪里都能看到这种文明化进程的例子，特别是与大众事务、习俗、狩猎等等相关的事情。但拳击却设法在这些事情中腾挪闪避，钻了空子，而其他运动，比如驱牛或斗牛，却没有。托利主义是事后追认这些事情的。它总是以回顾的方式运作，关乎归属感，
of honorary status as a British gentleman if you are not a kind of English yeoman? Is that what's going on? Something like that. I think boxing is a fraternity. I think it is now and it was then. I think there's a respect at pride and each other's strength. I mean, boxers, of course, talk each other down before a fight, but very rarely after one. So as with this one? As with this one. You know, Wellington referred to his troops as morbid in taciturn. And it was famous that the British infantry were quiet. They would stay quiet. whereas the French would go in with all that elan and they were famous for shouting and screaming in their attack,
关乎对你重要的事情是那些个人的事情，有价值的事情是那些近在咫尺、触手可及的事情。关于普赖兹奖金拳击，你能说的一点是，它确实非常触手可及。嗯，确切地说是触“两”可及。非常棒。每个人都这么做。那么，关于驯化拳击这个话题，是的。众所周知，伦敦规则最终被昆斯伯里侯爵规则所取代。
no less brave. But they were completely different styles and it would seem that Mendoza and Richmond and Molineer, who was a former black American slave, hugely popular in this country for what they were. Richmond was a page boy at George IV's coronation. Him and crib were minders on the door, they were bouncers on the door of a coronation dressed as page boys. There was a kind
而昆斯伯里侯爵，正如他的名字所暗示的那样，是一位贵族。这就是我们之前在奥斯卡·王尔德的剧集中已经提到过的那个昆斯伯里侯爵，他通过法庭对王尔德穷追猛打，最终把他送进了监狱。但他基本上引入了当今规范这项运动的拳击形式。这是怎么发生的？同样，从中能学到什么更广泛的教训吗？因为在维多利亚时期，贵族们一直在制定规则并成文化，把以前那些
of fraternity. Now, of course, I'm not saying there wasn't racism. Of course, there was racism, which was directed at them, but never to their face for obvious reasons. Now, I know we're going to run out of time, and Tom wants to ask about, Tom mentioned the Marcus of Queenspeer, but just one quick last thing before we get onto that. The political meaning of all this, because your book is about sport and liberty, and you have a line in this chapter, only Tories could be true sportsmen. Only Tories had bottom. Is this a kind of Tory England, kind of traditional, resistant to being improved, resistant to reform? You know, boxing has been criticised by what you might call do-gooders, and there's a sort of sense of it. People who like it seem to have this sense of
平民化的娱乐方式进行编码，不是吗？发生了什么？新规则——昆斯伯里规则——源自剑桥大学，年轻的绅士们在那里进行实战训练。当时有一种实战训练的风潮。拜伦就练过，对吧？拜伦练过。黑兹利特也练过。
it, as you said, being a kind of an underground continuity of history, a sense of tradition, all that kind of stuff. What this has reminded me of is Jacko McCako. The Fighting Monkey. The Fighting Monkey, who likewise was covered in Ruby. And that also, people were upset about the idea of animals pulverizing each other to death. But again, the same thing about do good as trying to clean it up. Humanity Dick, Tom, as you may remember, trying to stamp it out. So, Rob, that line that you have about this being kind of Toryism, is that a serious point? Yeah, it is a serious point.
各种各样的家伙都搞这个。昆斯伯里侯爵也是如此。实战训练的意义在于，正如黑兹利特所说，它不是拳击。它是拳击的一种表演形式。而在剑桥发生的事情是，他们用手套取代了赤拳，
The trouble with the point, although it was serious, is we never really know what Toryism is. because it's by definition, non-ideological, not up for definition, and endlessly adapting to the status quo. Only in that sense do we know what it is at any one time. But given what happened after, let's say after Cribb, there was a huge movement in England to civilize the people. And that movement was broadly speaking liberal, broadly speaking metropolitan, broadly speaking condescending to people who were considered rough, stupid and moronic. Now, Toryism took a position against that as time went by. It decided it wasn't that kind of politics.
他们引入了固定的回合、重量级，最后引入了医疗和健康控制。他们相信，拳击将会变得更加安全和美好。但当然，从某种意义上说，它掌握在年轻的剑桥本科生手中，而不是掌握在20世纪涌现出的那种凶猛、厚重的职业拳击手手中。所以，昆斯伯里规则虽然具有文明化的作用，但在我所称的约翰·L·沙利文、杰克·德普西等人的现代美国时代里，它却以一种有趣的方式变得更加暴力。好吧。那么，罗布，这真的太迷人了。
It was another kind of politics. So, as you know, from the book, we get examples of this civilization process all through the century, particularly it do with popular affairs, customs, hunting. and so on. But boxing, in particular, managed to wriggle its way through these things, whereas other sports, like bull running or bull baiting, didn't. Torreism took these things up retrospectively. It always works retrospectively about belonging,
我的意思是，我们可以聊上好几个小时。你书中写了这么多伟大的角色——门多萨，显而易见，那位犹太拳击手；莫利纽克斯；汤姆·克里布。这里其实有太多的细节需要剖析。对于真正对此感兴趣的人来说，你的书就是《这就是体育生活：1762年至1960年英国的体育与自由》（This Sporting Life, Sport and Liberty in England, 1762–1960），我极力向大家推荐。这是一本绝佳绝佳的读物。非常感谢罗布加入我们的《历史的剩余》（The Rest is History）。我知道你经常听这个播客，对吧？
about what the things that matter to you are the things that are personal, the things that count are the things that are around the corner and easy to hand. And one thing you can say about prize fighting was it was very, easy to hand. Well, very easy to two hands. Very good. Everybody did it. So on the topic of kind of taming boxing, yes. Famously, London rules is supplanted by the Marquis of Queensbury rules.
所以对我们来说，你能不仅作为嘉宾出演，而且还自愿收听，这是一种莫大的荣誉。我们全家人都非常喜欢它。你实际上还常常告诉我一些新知识。说实话，每次都挺让人震惊的。好吧，这真是个好消息。那么，汤姆，带着这个重磅炸弹，我们就要……叮铃铃。
And the Marcus of Queensbury, as his name suggests, is an aristocrat. This is the same Marcus of Queensbury, who we have already mentioned in our episodes on Oscar Wilde, who Harry's Wilde through the courts and ultimately gets him into prison. But he introduces essentially the form of boxing that nowadays governs the sport. How does that happen? And again, is there a kind of a broader lesson to learn from that? Because there is a process, isn't there, throughout the Victorian period of the aristocracy, drawing up rules and codifying what had previously been,
对，叮铃铃，叮铃铃。再见，大家。再见，伙计们。非常感谢你，罗布。大家再见。嗨，又见面了。我是来自《机密档案》（The Rest is Classified）的大卫。以下是我们之前提到的那段音频剪辑。
kind of plebeian ways of entertaining themselves? What happens? The new rules, the Queensbury rules, emanate out of Cambridge University, where young gentlemen spar. And there's a kind of fashion for sparring. So Byron does it, doesn't he? Byron does it. Haslett does it.
战胜毒品是我们的呼唤，这是一项正义的事业。在你们的帮助下，我们将取得胜利。巴勃罗·埃斯科瓦尔，麦德林贩毒集团头目。世界第14位富豪。他从很多方面来看都是个恐怖分子。这是集中在少数人手中的经济力量，也是犯罪分子的经济力量。他们通过勒索无法得到的东西，就会通过谋杀来获取。我不认为他表达过任何悔意。他试图把自己塑造为一个平民英雄，这种类似于
All kinds of chaps do this. And so does the Marcus of Greensbury. And the point about sparring is, as Haslitt said, it's not boxing. It's a representation of boxing. And what's happening at Cambridge is that they swap Babe Knuckles for gloves. they introduce fixed rounds, weights, they introduce in the end medical and health controls.
左翼革命逃亡者的人物。麦德林的几乎所有人都支持毒贩。不支持的人要么死了，要么成了靶子。如果你宣战，你就得预料到国家的反应。这是他做得太过火的时刻。自周末以来，麦德林已经发生了13起爆炸。到87年底，波哥大基本上成了一个战区。美国对国际反毒努力的投入将从1989年的不到3亿美元，
It's boxing, they believe, is going to be safer and better. But of course, in a sense, it is in the hands of young Cambridge undergraduate, but not in the hands of the kind of fast, heavy professional fighters that emerge in the 20th century. So, Queensby Rules is civilizing, but, in a funny way, it's even more violent in what I've called the modern American era of people like John L. Sullivan, Jack Dempsey, and others. Okay. Well, Rob, this has been absolutely fascinating.
增长到1991年的7亿多美元。一个确切的事实是，在哥伦比亚，没有人能真正免受毒品贩子刺客的威胁。这是一场连目标甚至都不是为了阻止可卡因流通的冲突。它的目标是击垮这个毒品恐怖分子。从这一点开始，一切都对你不利了。他正在建立的一切正在土崩瓦解。要想收听完整单集，请在您获取播客的任何地方收听《机密档案》。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
I mean, we could talk about this for ages. You've got so many great characters, Mendoza, obviously, the Jewish boxer, Molyneux, Tom Cribb. There's actually so much to unpick here. And for people who are really interested in this, your book is This Sporting Life, Sport and Liberty, in England, 1762, 9. 1960, and I cannot recommend it too highly. It is a wonderful, wonderful read. So thank you so much, Rob, for joining us on The Rest is History. I know you listen to the podcast, don't you?
我的意思是，我们可以谈论这个很久。你有那么多伟大的角色，门多萨，显而易见，犹太拳击手莫利纽克斯，汤姆·克里布。这里其实有很多东西可以剖析。对于对这个真正感兴趣的人，你的书是《1762至1960年英格兰的体育生活、体育与自由》，我极力推荐。这是一本非常非常精彩的读物。非常感谢罗布加入我们的“历史之余”。我知道你听这个播客，对吧？
So that is, for us, that is a great honour to have you not just appearing on it, but listening to it voluntarily. We all love it in our family. You actually tell me things. It's quite alarming, really, every time. Right. Well, that's very good news. So, Tom, on that bombshell, we will... Ding, ding.
所以对我们来说，非常荣幸不仅能请你来上节目，还能听到你自愿收听。我们全家都很喜欢它。你实际上告诉我很多事。真的很惊人，每一次。好吧，那真是个好消息。那么，汤姆，带着这个重磅炸弹，我们将……叮，叮。
Yeah, ding ding, ding. Bye, everybody. See you, guys. Thanks so much, Rob. And bye, everybody. Hi, again. It's David from the rest is classified. Here's that clip we mentioned earlier.
是的，叮，叮，叮。再见，各位。再见，伙计们。非常感谢罗布。再见，各位。嗨，大家好。我是来自《历史解密》的大卫。这就是我们刚才提到的片段。
Victory over drugs is our call. a just cause. And with your help, we are going to win. Pablo Escobar, the head of the Medelline drug cartel. The world's 14th, which is man. He was, in many ways, a terrorist. This is an economic power concentrated in a few hands and in criminal minds. What they cannot obtain by blackmail, they get by murder. And I don't think he expressed any regret at all. He tries to portray himself as a man of the people, this kind of
战胜毒品是我们的呼声。一个正义的事业。在你们的帮助下，我们将取得胜利。巴勃罗·埃斯科巴，麦德林贩毒集团头目。世界第十四位，也就是这个人。他在许多方面是个恐怖分子。这是一种集中在少数人手中和犯罪分子头脑中的经济力量。他们通过敲诈勒索得不到的东西，就会通过谋杀来获取。而且我认为他没有表达任何遗憾。他试图把自己塑造成一个平民的人，这种
like leftist revolutionary outlaw. Nearly everyone in Medellin supports the traffickers. Those who don't are either dead or targets. If you declare war, you've got to expect the state to respond. This is the moment where he goes too far. 13 bombs are gone off to Medellin since the weekend. By the end of 87, Bogota is essentially a war zone. US spending for international anti-drug efforts is going to grow from less than $300 million in 1989.
像左翼革命 outlaw。麦德林的几乎所有人都支持贩毒者。不支持的人要么死了，要么是靶子。如果你宣战，你就得预料到国家会作出反应。这是他走得太远的关键时刻。自周末以来，麦德林已经发生了13起爆炸。到87年底，波哥大基本上成了一个战区。美国对国际反毒品努力的支出将从1989年的不到3亿美元增加到
to more than 700 million by 1991. It is the certain knowledge that no one is really safe in Colombia from drug cartel assassins. It's a conflict where the goal wasn't even to stop, the flow of cocaine. It was to bring down this narco-terrorist. Everything has turned against him after this point. The whole thing he was building is collapsing. To hear the full episode, listen to the rest is classified wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
到1991年超过7亿美元。可以肯定的是，在哥伦比亚，没有人能真正免受毒品集团刺客的威胁。这是一场甚至连阻止可卡因流入都不是目标的冲突。其目的是打倒这个贩毒恐怖分子。从这一点开始，一切都对他不利了。他一直在建立的整个帝国正在崩溃。要收听完整单集，请在您获取播客的任何地方收听《历史解密》。该单集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。